non je sais que vous avez vu l'annoncé
vous vous êtes dit un truc de fou c'est
un truc de malade leeuw saint pierre et
tout macha mais non tu as oui mais non
parce que parce qu'on vend par le juste
après l'intro en fait
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
une nouvelle fois sur cette chaîne où on
parle de vidéos de tournage de matos de
montage de colorimétrie donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse et bien
n'hésitez pas à envisager de cliquer sur
le petit bouton s'abonner au site us
dans toute cette vidéo d'activer la
cloche tout ça tout ça parce qu'ici il
ya des choses très intéressantes pour
vous alors la semaine dernière il ya eu
une annonce qui a fait beaucoup de bruit
un cahier fait par cannon et c'était à
propos de leur nouveau boîtier le canon
eos r5 un boîtier hybride qui a des spex
sur le papier de ouf qui ont un petit
peu secoué tout le monde ça fait quand
même beaucoup de bruit et étonnamment
moi je n'ai pas du tout du tout du tout
était à ip par cette annonce et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi
dans cette vidéo parce que pour
comprendre l'ensemble de cette réflexion
ici il faut vraiment avoir tous les
éléments en tête donc ce n'est pas à
rester jusqu'à la fin sinon vous aurez
juste un morceau de la réflexion et vous
allez me faire des commentaires en me
disant des trucs pas très agréable et
tout machin ça c'est pas sympa c'est pas
cool mais revenons-en à nos moutons et
voyons tout de suite pourquoi je pense
que c'était auxerre 5 n'a rien pour
faire rêver du moins peu de chose de
plus que ce qu'on a actuellement sur mon
boitier est bien évidemment on n'est pas
dans une guéguerre de marquain je suis
pas en train de dire que sony c'est
mieux que nikon c'est mieux que cannon
c'est mieux que panasonic c'est mieux
toutes les caméras qui sortent
actuellement sont des petits bijoux 1
qui permettent de faire des choses
extraordinaires c'est juste vraiment sur
celle ci et sur certains points que je
voudrais appuyé parce que je pense que
ça s'applique à beaucoup de choses dans
la vidéo la grosse fitch heures c'est le
cas ni une ni meubles a beaucoup de gens
de ce canon eos r5 c'est la capacité de
filmer en 8k non cros paix en raw est
clairement c'est juste ou c'est une
fonctionnalité qu'on retrouve sur des
grosses grosses grosses caméras hyper
cher qui ne s'est jamais vu sur aucun
des slr c'est juste un truc de malade
sachant qu'on est en plein format en
plus de ça on pourra filmer en 4 2 2 10
bits en lob ou en hdr et ce jusqu'en 8 k
truc de malade et même faire de la 4k à
120 fps toujours en quête de 2,18 en
conservant l'autofocus et la
stabilisation est ce encore
c'est juste d'agde mais voilà où je veux
en venir c'est super ça c'est super mais
si on sort de la fiche technique et
qu'on se met dans la position de
quelqu'un qui fait des vidéos que ce
soit en professionnel au monde amateur
bien que la en amateur je vois vraiment
pas trop à part le fait de se faire
plaisir à jouer vraiment pas trop
l'intérêt
mais si on se met à la place de
quelqu'un qui filme régulièrement qui
shoote régulièrement en fait toutes ses
specs ce extraordinaire c'est juste un
énorme handicap dit ou bien si vous
filmez henrot en 8k en gros une minute
de fichiers vidéo à ce format là ça
correspond à plus de 100 giga d' espace
de stockage 100 giga c'est juste ça veut
dire que votre carte ses fastes de 250
giga vous pouvez enregistrer 2 minutes
30 grand max dessus donc déjà ça pose un
problème sur quoi on enregistre voilà on
n'a pas la possibilité d'enregistrer sur
un ssd externes comme on peut faire sur
black magic par exemple donc c'est
vraiment sur la carte ses fastes sachant
que ce boîtier il a un double slot un
ses fastes 1 sd mais à des débits pareil
la sdc impossible il ne pourra pas
enregistrer de sud on sera forcément sur
la ses fastes qui coûte beaucoup plus
cher et donc on sera vraiment très très
limité sur le temps d'enregistrement ou
alors il faudra plein de cartes et
s'arrêter toutes les deux minutes où
toutes les cinq minutes si on a des
cartes de 512 giga la limite est là le
prix on est sur un truc de fou et puis
il ya le stockage de ces fichiers là moi
je sais que j'ai du gros stockage j'ai
un raid de d'itéra bas
un truc comme ça clairement ça suffira
pas il faudra des sous stations de
stockage beaucoup plus importante donc
on est déjà sur quelque chose qui est
pas super ergonomique qui ça veut dire
que si on a envie de filmer quelque
chose d'un peu long une quinzaine une
vingtaine de minutes
ben c'est juste mort pour le faire d'un
trait c'est impossible
en plus de ça une des grosse
problématique et les grosses limitation
de nos boîtiers seller form factor on a
des boîtiers de plus en plus petits
comme le alpha cède 3 comme le z 6 comme
le gh5 et forcément avec cette petite
taille on a des problèmes de chauffe et
là aussi la question apparemment il
était question sur ses terres ses
recettes de limiter à 5 minutes
l'enregistrement ans robbie cas si c'est
le cas c'est clairement pour une
histoire de chauffe et là aussi la 4k
120 fps en cas de 2 10 bits
est-ce qu'elle va passer sur la carte sd
j'ai des doutes est-ce que là aussi elle
va être limité en terme de temps parce
qu'il va falloir un débit de malades
il va falloir que le boîtier traite tout
ça donc sur le papier c'est super mais
la mise en place derrière par un vrai
vidéaste elle est un petit peu plus
compliqué alors on pourrait se dire oui
mais bon on va pouvoir a enregistré via
par exemple comme je suis en train de le
faire là un atom hausse en externe par
le port hdmi du boîtier et ben non on va
pouvoir mais on va être limitée à 2 la
4k à 60 fps tout simplement parce qu'on
a un hdmi qui est en 2.0 et que ce port
là ne supporte pas plus que la 4k à 60
fps dont clairement on est limité à
l'internât et c'est assez fou d'ailleurs
parce que justement sur plein de boîtier
on se plaint que certaines choses on
peut pas les faire en interne qu'il faut
forcément de l'externe un moniteur mais
là pour le coup c'est l' inverse on
pourra faire plein de choses en interne
mais pas en externe et du coup les
choses en interne sont limitées par
plein de spécificités du boîtier dont ce
port hdmi
au delà de ça il sait quelque chose de
plus générale on a toujours tendance à
vouloir plus à vouloir plus de fps à
vouloir plus de qualité à vouloir plus
d'informations à vouloir plus de plage
dynamique
le problème c'est que plus on a
d'informations plus on a de quantité en
fait d'informations plus les fichiers
sont gros et plus les fichiers sont
lourds à traiter alors apparemment
l'euro qui va être présent sur les
ressert 5
ça va être un gros con presser un peu
comme le pro réseau par exemple
mais est-ce que ça va être
les jets à traiter ou lourd à traiter ça
on sait pas trop ça va dépendre aussi
des logiciels le progrès 0 par exemple
passe super bien sur final cut parce que
c'est le codec natif de la timeline
mais pour ce road cannon ça reste à voir
il faudra peut-être des machines qui
soit quand même gaillarde
au-delà de ça mais morrow ou pas de l'a8
cas en cas de de 10 bits
il ya intérêt quand même à avoir une
machine derrière qui carbure des fois
sur une très bonne machine on met quatre
ou cinq plans multicam en 4k elle tire
un peu la gueule il faut dire ce qui est
alors en 8k
j'imagine même pas le truc que ça va
être ça va être très lourd à porter tout
ça pour dire que on veut d'une nouvelle
fischer on veut toujours plus sur nos
boîtiers on va toujours plein de trucs
mais est-ce qu'on est prêts à les
assumer derrière pour le stockage pour
le traitement
c'est pas si évident que ça et puis au
delà de ça on a des boîtiers
actuellement qui sont très très bon et
qui peut faire plein de choses
et le meilleur moyen de gagner en
qualité avec ses boîtiers là c'est tout
simplement d'améliorer la composition
d'améliorer le storytelling d'améliorer
l'éclairage ya moyen de faire des trucs
assez fou avec justement ce que je
disais ces boîtiers qu'on a actuellement
qui sont de très très bonne machine
quelle que soit la marque la wicca
clairement on va y venir on y viendra
comme on est venu à la 4 capes mais tout
de suite c'est un petit peu prématuré
l'avicca raw encore plus prématuré je
pense pour le commun des mortels il y
aura bien sûr des gens une toute petite
minorité des gens qui vont être
intéressés par ce format là mais pour la
grande majorité des utilisateurs
ça n'a strictement aucune utilité et
puis il feint faut pas se leurrer non
plus le prix qu'elle n'a pas encore
annoncé de prix pour ce boîtier mais
faut pas rêver ça sera pas à trois mille
balles ça sera au moins à mon avis je
mets un petit pari là dessus je suis pas
sûr je suis pas devin mais ça sera au
moins entre cinq et sept mille euros et
peut-être même plus je ne sais pas la
voix ça sera pas du tout un boîtier
adressé à des gens comme moi qui sommes
des indépendants et qui n'a donc
clairement rien à de la vie cas
actuellement le côté quand même hyper
positif de tout ça parce qu'il y en a ce
qui est chouette c'est que cannes on a
quand même mis un gros coup de pied dans
la fourmilière parce que on était dans
une espèce de stagnation depuis quelques
temps sur les boîtiers sur les specs
savait rien vraiment qu'ils sortaient du
lot avec une nouveauté extraordinaire
est là clairement cannon
on fait un truc de malade même si pour
l'instant on n'a encore rien vu et ça
reste des chiffres sur un bout de papier
ça veut dire que dans un avenir proche
il ya de fortes chances que sony que
nikon que panasonic se sortent les
doigts du cul et nous sortent des choses
un petit peu plus sexy et qui
potentiellement seront peut-être un peu
plus utilisable que ce genre de fonction
là et puis on est bien d'accord les
auxerre 5 ça sera sûrement une très très
très très très bonne caméra ça je dis
pas le contraire
je dis juste que est ce qu'on aura
l'utilité vous et moi il ya 95% des gens
qui font de la vidéo
j'en suis pas hyper sûr pour certaines
activités la pub par exemple ça peut
être je pense une très bonne opération
mais ça va rester vraiment je pense très
marginale à mon avis c'est pas un
boîtier qui va avoir un succès
monumental comme a pu la voir par
exemple alpha 7 3 je pense pas que tout
le monde va switcher est passé sur un
air sain mais ça c'est ce que moi je
pense et si d'ailleurs vous avez aimé
cette petite réflexion sur le canot sert
5 vous pouvez bien entendu mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo pouvez aussi
aller voir d'autres vidéos que j'ai fait
à propos d'autres boîtiers qui s'affiche
par ici pour éventuellement vous abonner
aussi à la chaîne ça fait toujours
plaisir et puis moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo